[Music]
afghans are preparing to hold their
first friday prayers under taliban
control but it's being reported taliban
fighters may be allowed into mosques
with them a confidential report by the
un claims the armed group has priority
lists of people it wants to arrest they
include afghans who've served with the
military and the police as well as
intelligence units the un says the
taliban have been carrying out targeted
door-to-door visits
at kabul international airport the
evacuation of diplomats and afghans
continues the u.s moved 3 000 people on
thursday including those waiting for
visas nato says about 18 000 people have
been evacuated since the taliban took
over on sunday
and there have been several
demonstrations on thursday to mark
afghanistan's independence day at least
two people were killed in the city of
assad about where the taliban used
gunfire to clear crowds but in a rare
move fighters allowed shia muslims to
commemorate the holy day of ashura as
rob mcbride reports from kabul
at kabul airport's main terminal this is
crowd control taliban style
volleys of gunfire scatter people in
panic
at another gate even more desperate
scenes as the airport continues to be
besieged
and at the side of the airport where the
u.s military evacuation is taking place
private defense contractors there use
tear gas
at the british embassy compound long
lines gathered daily to apply for
special visas with promises from the
taliban of amnesty for those who worked
with foreign forces and safe passage to
the airport
but many doubt the taliban's promises
fears raised by its treatment of
protesters wanting to retain the
national flag
deadly clashes with taliban fighters
have taken place in the city of
jalalabad with emotions running even
higher as afghanistan celebrates
independence day
there have been further confrontations
in the city of asadabad
the violence of this independence day
has raised tensions in what is already a
very highly charged atmosphere and by
coincidence it comes on the same day as
ashura the most important date in the
shia calendar a ritual observed here by
the minority hazara community
targeted in the past by isil bombers the
commemoration this year is also
overshadowed by the current upheaval
and concerns the community may face
further alienation under a taliban
government
as i see it if the government is going
to be dominated by just one ethnic group
it makes us worried that the country
could slip back into civil war and
destruction
on the streets of kabul there are signs
of life returning to something like
normal with more business opening and
hopes for a new start but now we are
going everyone was tired of the previous
government people are hopeful for
whatever is coming and that business
will be better but the views of a
nervous population remain mixed
it's better for our future if the
country is free of all these troubles
and his fortunes
we don't want to go back to the previous
taliban era when young people would have
to follow the strict dress code or get
beaten up
with more taliban patrolling the streets
there's also been the return of a
familiar sight traffic police in their
distinctive uniforms back on duty
a small comfort for a population in need
of any kind of reassurance right now
rob mcbride's life for us in kabul rob
the taliban had been saying it was going
to give an amnesty to who people had
worked with foreign forces and in the
military and yet we're hearing about
these door-to-door searches what's going
on
i mean that still remains the assurance
from the taliban but this report issued
through the u.n uh it does make very
worrying reading i think it will gain a
lot of traction here with people in
afghanistan given the taliban's record
in the past and also its reputation so
the report talks about
former military and also intelligence
personnel from the former regime being
targeted a taliban going door-to-door
also worryingly it talks about the
families of those people if they don't
get the individuals themselves the
families are then targeted as a way of
putting pressure on those individuals to
come forward to try to identify uh who
they are and also talks about in for
recruiting informers as try to
presumably set up a network to try to
identify all of these individuals
this as we know goes against what the
taliban has been saying from the very
start it has no interest in
recriminations reprisals this he wants a
different type of regime it wants to uh
start afresh
but we do know that from you know out in
the provinces at local levels as this
conflict uh has swept across the country
there have been cases of uh people being
targeted there have been reprisals
people have been killed and the question
is how much is this the work of taliban
even at a local level or how much is it
just a reprisal between individuals in
villages between families or ethnic
groups i mean it gets very messy and
very confusing at uh as you get out into
the provinces of afghanistan it's it's
not very clear-cut about what is a
targeted reprisal attack so that's the
question really is is uh how much of
this is at a national level that there
might be lists or that might be in kabul
that people are targeted we do know for
example that the defence minister here
about two weeks ago was targeted that's
before the taliban took control they uh
targeted his residents with a suicide uh
bomb attack so that's the question for
people here but many people here are
certainly given the unease about the
taliban taking control certainly will
believe this to be true we'll have
concerns about it and it all adds to the
general pressure to try to get out of
afghanistan you were telling us just a
moment ago rob about the situation in
the at the kabul airport and we were
talking about the taliban checkpoints
the chaos and the streets causing even
more difficulties for people trying to
get there but of course that's not going
to let up is it
now that does still continue we know
that the taliban have closed off the uh
airport road the road to that terminal
uh as a way of trying to limit the
numbers of people heading there of
trying to uh stop uh to try to restrict
the flow of people there so that
continues and we do know that there are
continuing chaotic scenes all around the
perimeter of the uh the airport as the
evacuation flight by the u.s military
continues we've spoken to the civil
aviation authority just about their
plans now we do know that they've been
gradually trying to restore the terminal
building
and they do hope at some point they tell
us to restore commercial flights
remember there hasn't been a commercial
flight a flight that you can buy a
ticket and get on a seat
on a seat of since last sunday so it's
been it's uh the whole of this week has
been without these commercial flights
we've just had the military flights and
the special charters so they hope at
some point but the problem is for the
civil aviation authority they tell us
that the whole terminal building is in
the control of the us military at the
moment and also the operations area
until they say it's okay that uh
civilian staff can move in and they can
start looking at uh restoring commercial
flights then there will be no uh
commercial flights uh but i want to show
you just want to show you something else
that's actually doing the rounds on
social media at the moment and this is
what purports to be an official us
document some sort of permit or visa and
it says that it allows the bearer to you
present this at a security checkpoint
and to consular officers to access
flight evacuation flights to the united
states now words like that in a moment
like this are golden uh it is very
seductive we have no idea if this is
genuine or not it looks genuine but the
fact is that this may have been if it is
genuine it may have been issued to some
people it has now been uploaded onto
social media it has been distributed
people have been printing these out and
we know that a number of people have
been taking to this this to the airport
in the hope of getting on a flight so it
just adds to all of this sense of uh
half truths uh uh rumors etc of whether
something might work and might get you
through a roadblock and get you near the
airport and all adds to the general
sense of chaos here at the moment
especially with regards to the airport
and departures through it rob mcbride
reporting for us from kabul rob thanks
well thousands of families are still
looking for shelter in kabul after being
forced out of their homes by the
taliban's offensive more than 400
families who left provinces in the north
of afghanistan are sheltering in a
school the un had said earlier this
month that more than
244 000 people have been displaced in
just three months
along its partners are providing
temporary accommodation along with basic
health services
ready to use trapatic food for all those
children who are hungry and have made
this journey with hungry stomachs and
unicef is also providing a psychosocial
support to the children who have seen
devastation and impact of war there are
also child friendly spaces here where
children are coming and spending time
facebook twitter and linkedin say
they've changed their services in
afghanistan to protect security and
privacy of users it says afghans can now
shield posts from unknown accounts they
can also remove the ability of other
users to see a list of their online
friends those with facebook and
instagram will receive notifications
about the new features the changes
follow recommendations from activists
journalists and civil society groups
southern haiti's only medical oxygen
plant has been left severely damaged
from sunday's power